yesterday the united states government
the department of justice arrested two
individuals and they recovered 3.6
billion dollars of stolen bitcoin this
is an absolutely crazy crazy story now
here's the deal some of you may not know
but bitfinex a very large exchange was
hacked in 2016 for over four billion
dollars worth of bitcoin and now the
department of justice years and years of
hard work culminating in the arrest of
two individuals and the recovery of
billions of dollars now who the hell
exactly are they arrested first we have
dutch lichtenstein and heather morgan
both in their 30s morgan was a writer
literally at forbes she had a verified
twitter account even wrote pieces like
tips to protect your business from cyber
criminals you couldn't make up this
script and of course the man dutch
lichenstein he was a yc alum from y
combinator he's a tech entrepreneur this
story is crazy if we then go ahead and
we look at what exactly they describe
themselves as things like tech
entrepreneur explorer occasional
magician coder investor interested in
blockchain technology automation and big
data what is going on nobody knows now
of course if we go and we look at
actually what was taken or what was
recovered by the us government the
hackers or these individuals are accused
of conspiring to launder almost 120 000
bitcoin after it was stolen from
bitfenix in more than 2 000 unauthorized
transactions back in 2016. at the time
that bitcoin was only valued at 71
million now it's valued at over 4
billion dollars but only about 94 000 of
the roughly 120 000 bitcoin have
actually been recovered in this effort
by the department of justice now there's
a lot of work that went into this inside
of the actual filing around the arrest
there are all sorts of graphics and
different things that are showing the
tracing of funds on an open public
blockchain as we continue to say the
choice currency of criminals around the
world is still the us dollar because if
you use bitcoin and you're a criminal
you're a bad dude we can track it down
it's a immutable ledger those
transactions are on that public
blockchain forever and that's exactly
what law enforcement did here is these
criminals had their fingers on a
keyboard and the law enforcement
officers that were chasing them down
were able to find out exactly what they
were doing trace those funds end up
arresting them and then recovering a ton
of the funds as well
and so what exactly did they do they
were buying all kinds of stuff literally
gift cards nfts playstations the whole
nine yards this is exactly what i
imagined if a teenager was to steal a
bunch of money and then go on a shopping
spree you'd go stay at hotels you'd do
uber you'd buy things at walmart and
also maybe get yourself a playstation
well that's what they were doing too
which is pretty damn incredible now one
of the key points to this whole story is
that right now in this moment the united
states government has almost four
billion dollars of bitcoin on their
balance sheet now technically it is not
the u.s government's money they should
be giving it back to bitfinex even
though bitfinex already made their
customers whole but the us government
right now in this moment has more
bitcoin on their balance sheet than any
other country in the world and the way
that i look at this is that it's a
national security issue even if the us
government gives this bitcoin back
two-bit fedex the us government should
go buy more bitcoin to replace it and
keep bitcoin on their balance sheet that
national security issue is that there's
only 21 million bitcoin and the longer
that we wait the more expensive it
becomes and whoever has the courage and
conviction early will have the outsized
reward every country eventually is going
to adopt bitcoin and so the united
states should be the leader we must act
now the stakes are too high but of
course that four billion dollars sitting
on their balance sheet probably won't be
there long this last tweet we have shows
they're gonna have to give it back it's
not technically theirs but on the other
hand it kind of is according to jack
newald it also shows us the department
of justice is closely examining and
deploying massive resources to the
crypto industry this is one of the
largest recoveries of assets that have
ever been stolen by the us government
just happens to be in bitcoin and it
further reinforces the fact if you're a
bad dude don't use bitcoin because law
enforcement will find you and on top of
that now that the us government's got 4
billion sitting on their balance sheet i
think they should keep it they won't
because they owe it back to bitfinex but
maybe they should go buy more billions
of bitcoin and they should keep that on
their balance sheet